brought shame for free offer how's he
going everyone my name is Peter Byrne
and welcome to fatal flame - this is the
second one I heard that the second one
is more scary and it took me forever to
set this up I'm playing it from my
computer so oh I was like who's that and
apparently with her sister we're looking
no we are a girl and we're looking for
our sister I think she's dead I don't
really understand there's like a intro
movie thingy and I've seen that like
five thousand times we could it took me
like five thousand times to set this up
and I'm not gonna watch a movie but ah
she really wants I sister that's me
Marv you anyway I have Ezio with me day
and ink to ink do you wanna be and I
ready up let's come here probably watch
the thinking distracted
oh sorry
what's going on ink you scared
she's care
butterfly no
Sam Noah
yeah the butterfly watch out watch out
it's gonna kill her it's gonna kill her
no no no the butterfly Maya
oh geez group now mosque village
Fatal Frame 2 crimson butterfly I'm
really excited to play this game my hair
it's really good and really scary so I'm
really good I finally a long time ago a
second eye socket it's acute during a
festival people who get lost in the
woods are trapped by the village Oh
could this be that place I'm scared I'm
scared I'm scared okay so that's our
sister and she's I don't know what's
wrong with her she's really weird before
nobody here that's kind of creepy
let's go just go I'm pumped yeah no
that's biggest ways I can't do that but
as you can see it's kind of similar to
Silent Hill to you if you remember that
let's play but I heard this is this from
what I've seen this is actually scary I
didn't think Silent Hill was that scary
something is on the ground and I have a
keyboard and usually it's like a I don't
know whether it's call even control back
back several pieces of paper and photo
and news clipping geological serving
missing with the sort of constructing
all God's names prone to miss I'm
assuming mikuma Mara I do like I
survived dispatch the area has gone
missing when today I did investigate the
side would be submerged in the dam would
bill and there Peter
it seems like a follow-up to that other
news clipping the search for moose
Masami mikuma ah japanese name is not my
thing
the surviving missing since fourth of
this month came to close yesterday sir
me kumara had been helping to connect
the joke on several all the other all
the other missing for ten days
oh noes a photo of a man and a woman are
attached to the news clipping and now we
have them in our file and we can look at
who sees this I wonder it's such a grill
is here such a creepy look this way
who's this I wonder
ah she doing huh you think you're tough
mm-hmm you think you're tough hmm
missing with me hmm
think you're deaf you think your job hmm
you know you're talking to huh you think
you're tough
you think your dad hmm okay I should
stop harassing my sister anyway let's go
pump
no I'm laughs mom that's biggest once
okay let's go oh yeah Oh sad lady that's
creepy
that's creepy she's walking in slow mode
too so that's super creepy
okay so let's go
Katzie
and wonder if anyone's here uh
it's another creepy
no way oh she has three arms you know
wait
okay we're inside get your finger tough
hmm you think you're tough you think
you're tough hmm hmm you think you're
tough
okay let's go oh oh I don't know what I
did I miss pulsers on there we go I'm
sorry that's [ __ ] yeah okay let's go
how do I open doors there we go oh oh
are they twins or something
why why why are they going in here I
don't understand why let's say I were
lost in the woods I wouldn't just
randomly walk into a building that looks
older than me isn't anybody here it
doesn't look like anyone is there just
go back go back
should we go inside no you shouldn't
that's a bad idea
look I should skate you Maya Maya what's
wrong
this is really really creepy
Oh
really really really
Ezio I don't want to kill
huh so touching your boob did that I
don't know I don't know and we should
continue walking that was like the
creepiest cutscene ever I'm serious I
think that was you think you're deaf you
think your dad hmm
you can get that no but seriously ah Wow
the really wasn't ready for night go to
phone
voice-acting don't go too far yeah
let's go here it's shiny objects let's
pick it up
I got this
huh actually I don't go there we go a
woman's no big woman's a big one I heard
rumors about the last village before
long ago the mascara occurred on that
day of the ceremony the village was
wiped from the map twin DD statues in
the forest they lost people too
oh that's what we saw earlier once you
pass through the gate however you cannot
go back the village internally eternally
relieves that night of death then sing
latter of a woman is said to echo
throughout the village the only survivor
of the massacre at the village was a
lone one we saw a lone woman earlier
let's go upstairs because why not why
not
nothing scary up here yeah yeah yeah I'm
so happy I'm so happy my sister so slow
hurry up hurry up hurry up let's go
let's go on them
get us go here
okay count this padlock you think you're
tough
you think you're tough mm-hmm if you
could tap okay let's go
yeah and then downstairs cos ah I wish
it didn't go without here shiny objects
shiny oh it's just a laughs never mind
this is really disorienting when they
change angle and stuff oh I know where
we are
can we go in here doesn't gain a special
about the closet can we go here what
goes on here sister
empty ah it's the door why do I keep
cooking that hello lady
oh oh that's not good I would have left
right there
No
a she's searching for me that's not good
it should work yes it does she walks on
her own
stop walking on her own it's great babe
stop walking she really likes walking
this guy mmm she really likes walking
you can stop walking up I cut mom no she
keeps on walking okay keep on walking
oh not three Masumi it's me Miyako I
came here to look for you let's go home
together together we can make it call me
if you find this I'll be nearby I miss
you I wonder if anyone's really here I
can't go in here can I go down here cold
down wind is blowing oh they'll land
rest is left in the backyard in the
early yeah but how do I go there about
pushing my sister I think your dad you
think your dad what about here it's
gotta be the lawyers why why ah this is
why I don't like Asian or Japanese games
can see so weird
okay what is this son there's dust
inside has to be believes in a long time
okay very interesting thank you very
much
thank you very much where do I go hey
y'all
why are you so slow Wow
I love this out right wait wait
no no I don't want to read that where do
I go ah okay let's go back then cuz
apparently I can go there wait there has
to be some huh perfect I forgot to go
how to steam
okay let's go back hey guess
all right why is she door closed on his
own that's good
oh oh she's so creepy okay let's follow
her
it was upstairs right yeah
what what do you want now what what is
that you think you're tired what
happened
oh that creepy look oh there is someone
over here yeah I saw it too I was going
there but you
so let's go there is why the [ __ ] not
let's go oh now it works hang go
fighters cuz I'm manly except I'm a girl
shiny objects yeah yes shiny objects
strange hats please oh really
really you could tell that there's a
slash like perfect this camera is made
by doctor all hazel hazel Hayes Hall
never might to take the photograph of
being in the spiritual place that
normally cannot be seen it can reveal
events from the past through lingering
thoughts of individuals it is also be
able to further experience being envious
pinion even taking a photo of dancing
being an extrovert effects but semi
tense creates a sort of link with them
if the camera obscura [ __ ] stop writing
to me okay sorry main upper hand I found
it from inside LA
dangerous
uh-oh
what is that oh it's camera sweet
no I hate this cutscene slow takes
pictures impossible we knew that
no no no no no something bad is gonna
happen
okay I got it we can think photos and
stuff seems too dangerous
why is it dangerous okay I guess it's
dangerous
the camera obscura me what's that
she just said it are you oh my god
here's someone here probably yeah
this is so Japanese like two girls and
they're all Oh